Traduttore: Roberto Minelli
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Oggi vi parlerò di alberi e di foreste.
Vi parlerò di alberi,
e di foreste, per due motivi:
il primo è molto personale -
sono la mia passione,
che ho trasformato nel mio lavoro.
Il secondo, invece, interessa tutti
ed è il motivo che noi, come umanità,
ci stiamo progressivamente disconnettendo
dagli alberi e dalle foreste.
Nel corso dei millenni,
lasciamo sempre meno spazio,
sul pianeta, a questi sistemi
e li stiamo progressivamente
sostituendo con altre cose:
i campi, le città,
gli aeroporti, le strade
e tutta una serie di sistemi
che noi pensiamo siano più utili
o fondamentali per la nostra civiltà.
Ma ci siamo realmente chiesti
come sarebbe il mondo senza alberi?
Lo sappiamo?
Intendo: come cambierebbe
la qualità della nostra vita,
senza le foreste attorno a noi?
Una serie di domande -
ragioniamoci un po'.
Ma, facciamo un passo indietro.
Partiamo dall'inizio,
da quando eravamo bambini
e sognavamo - molti di voi,
sono sicuro, l'hanno fatto -
di costruirci una casetta lassù,
in cima agli alberi.
Un posto strano per costruire una casa,
però così affascinante.
Ci dava una visione
completamente diversa del mondo:
lo guardavamo dall'alto
e ci sembrava, in quella prospettiva,
che le cose fossero,
forse, al posto giusto.
Io penso che il motivo
per cui da bambini, nella nostra infanzia,
pensiamo che gli alberi siano
il luogo dove va costruita la casa
è perché, in fondo, gli alberi
sono stati la prima casa dell'umanità.
Noi siamo evoluti
scendendo poi da quegli alberi
e dando inizio -
assumendo così la posizione eretta -
proprio all’Antropocene,
a quel periodo nel quale
l'uomo sta cambiando il mondo.
E l'ha fatto, innanzitutto,
proprio togliendo gli alberi dal paesaggio
e sostituendoli dapprima
con l'agricoltura, con i campi;
poi abbiamo scoperto il petrolio,
il carbone, il metano, l'energia.
E con l'energia siamo riusciti
a costruire le città,
dove stiamo portando la civiltà
nell'ultima fase della sua esistenza.
In questo passaggio, chiaramente
ci stiamo allontanando dagli alberi
e quindi ora, se ripensiamo
a quella casetta che volevamo costruire,
ci rendiamo conto che, forse,
è irraggiungibile
e stiamo cercando
di trovarne un surrogato.
Quindi, gli appartamenti
più ambiti di Milano
adesso diventano una cosa così:
invece di avere la casetta sull'albero,
stiamo portando proprio
gli alberi sulle nostre case.
Questo, però, è un cambiamento
nel paradigma tra noi e gli alberi:
noi prima eravamo ospiti della natura,
adesso la ospitiamo -
in una forma addomesticata -
sulle nostre case.
E, mentre facciamo questo,
siamo sempre di più su questo pianeta.
Ieri, eravamo 7.600.000 e più persone;
sono nate 200mila persone in più ieri -
70 milioni quest’anno.
Una nuova Italia.
E, contemporaneamente,
abbiamo sempre meno foreste:
circa il 50 percento delle foreste
sono scomparse negli ultimi 500 anni
e ogni anno sul pianeta scompaiono -
scompare una superficie
di foresta tropicale
che è pari a cinque volte la Lombardia.
E allora, nello studiare
il rapporto tra foreste e uomini,
mi sono chiesto:
“Perché non facciamo, semplicemente,
il rapporto matematico
tra la superficie delle foreste
e il numero di uomini?”.
Questo rapporto è espresso
in quel grafico, in quella linea:
come vedete sta cambiando
molto rapidamente.
Nel 1990, quando quel grafico inizia,
io mi laureavo in scienze forestali.
E gli uomini in quel momento,
ogni uomo della Terra,
aveva quasi 8.000 m² di foresta.
Sono passati solo 25 anni - 28 anni -
e oggi io ne ho 5.400 di m²,
circa il 30% in meno.
E quando i miei figli, che siedono lì
e mi stanno guardando, si laureeranno,
bene, loro ne avranno solo 4.000, di m².
Il 50% in meno, da me ai miei figli.
In una sola generazione dimezziamo
il rapporto tra foreste e uomini.
Ora, noi siamo una società civile,
sviluppata, facciamo queste cose;
dovremmo razionalmente capire
dove stiamo andando
e capire dove questo ci porterà.
Ma, realmente, lo sappiamo?
Intendo, lo stiamo facendo
con cognizione di causa?
Sappiamo esattamente
cosa fanno gli alberi per noi?
O ci stiamo ancora comportando
come i cowboy nella prateria
infinita del Far West,
pensando che le risorse del pianeta
siano semplicemente infinite,
che possiamo prendere quello che vogliamo?
Nella realtà,
dovremmo cominciare a ragionare
come gli astronauti dentro una capsula,
dove l'aria, l'acqua, il cibo -
tutto è limitato,
tutto va gestito in maniera responsabile
per poter continuare il viaggio.
Ritorniamo alle foreste.
Sappiamo cosa hanno fatto per noi,
e cosa stanno facendo?
Beh, se lo chiedete a un bambino
cosa ci fanno le foreste,
la prima risposta è: il legno!
Il legno, certo.
Potremmo definirlo quasi
l'eroe nascosto della civilizzazione.
Ci ha sempre accompagnato -
dai primi strumenti
che abbiamo preso in mano
per diventare poi cacciatori,
poi agricoltori,
fino allo strumento principe
per costruire le nostre case;
era rinnovabile,
cresceva da solo attorno a noi.
Il legno poi - dal legno, poi,
abbiamo fatto il fuoco.
E con il fuoco ci siamo impadroniti
di una forma di energia;
questo ci ha reso completamente diversi
da tutti gli altri animali sul pianeta,
perché con l'energia
la potenza dell'uomo
è potuta crescere in maniera enorme.
Il fuoco tutt'oggi è importante:
la bioenergia - bruciare il legno -
rappresenta il 60 percento
dell'energia rinnovabile d'Europa,
più della somma di tutte
le altre energie rinnovabili.
Ma il legno, poi, ci ha dotato
di un'altra cosa: della carta.
La carta che è stata
il supporto delle idee dell'uomo,
il supporto della cultura.
Il ponte della cultura
da uno Stato all'altro,
da una persona all'altra,
da una generazione all'altra.
Senza la carta - io sono sicuro -
oggi non ci sarebbe TED.
Questi servizi del bosco
sono servizi materiali, concreti, fisici
che possiamo toccare.
E le foreste, però,
ci danno molto altro -
tutta una serie di servizi
che noi definiamo immateriali,
ma che sono importantissimi.
Facciamo fatica a descriverli,
però li capiamo:
le foreste regolano
il ciclo dell'acqua, ad esempio.
Il 70 percento dell'acqua
che torna dalla Terra verso l'atmosfera
per poi riprecipitare come pioggia,
bene, il 70 percento
passa attraverso le foglie.
Gli alberi, poi, proteggono
il suolo dall'erosione,
e il suolo è il substrato
sul quale possiamo produrre cibo -
possiamo produrre tutto quello
che serve per la nostra vita.
Gli alberi sono la base
della bellezza dei paesaggi,
sono la culla della diversità.
Gran parte degli organismi viventi
vivono nelle foreste,
e proteggere le foreste
è l'unico modo che abbiamo
per poterle conservare.
Infine - è argomento di questi giorni -
gli alberi cercano, con quanto possono,
di mitigare i cambiamenti climatici.
Circa il 30 percento
delle nostre emissioni di gas serra
vengono riassorbite dagli alberi
e trasformate in legno.
Quindi, gli alberi fanno tutto questo
e io mi chiedo:
ma se tutti noi sappiamo
il valore di queste cose -
il legno, il fuoco, la carta,
il paesaggio, l'aria, l'acqua,
elementi fondamentali della nostra vita -
com'è possibile che accettiamo
di ridurre del 50%
il rapporto tra foreste-uomo
in una sola generazione?
Bene, io credo che il problema
stia, alla base, nel valore;
nel valore che noi diamo a queste cose,
nel valore reale di mercato
rispetto al valore intrinseco che hanno.
Ragioniamoci un attimo.
Cos'è il valore, alla fine?
Il valore, nella nostra
economia di mercato,
non è altro che l'incontro - si dice -
tra la domanda e l'offerta.
Tra quanti cercano una cosa
e quanti sono disposti a venderla.
Questo ci produce un prezzo
che, moltiplicato per una quantità,
ci dà un valore.
Vado in questo mercato
e i peperoni costano 2 euro al chilo:
ne voglio 2 chili, pago 4 euro.
Semplice.
Ora, riusciamo a mettere gli alberi,
le foreste e le loro funzioni
in quest'equazione?
È molto difficile.
Dov'è il mercato della diversità,
della biodiversità?
Ad esempio, chi paga
per avere l'aria pulita?
Quanto è il valore del paesaggio?
Abbiamo dei problemi nell'inserire
i servizi ecosistemici immateriali -
i servizi che il bosco ci dona
e che non hanno confini -
in uno schema che è quello
che guida le nostre logiche
quando scegliamo cosa fare
di quello che sta attorno a noi.
Quando un contadino dell'Amazzonia
deve decidere cosa fare della sua foresta
applica questa logica,
e non sa dove inserire gli alberi.
E, quindi, l'unica soluzione che trova
è quella di tagliarli e sostituirli
con la canna da zucchero, con la soia.
Con qualcosa che, invece,
sa vendere in quel mercato.
Io credo che oggi, se vogliamo cambiare
questo percorso nel quale siamo avviati,
l'unica è trovare un modo
di inserire in questo schema logico
anche le funzioni che gli alberi hanno
e che non ci sono rappresentate.
Dobbiamo ritornare a dare
un valore materiale
alle funzioni immateriali
che le foreste ci danno.
Una soluzione c'è,
ed è rappresentata -
già oggi - dai satelliti.
Sembra un passo molto grande,
salire nello spazio:
ma, attorno a noi, sopra le nostre teste,
sono in orbita ormai decine,
centinaia di satelliti
che guardano il pianeta
in maniera continua.
E riescono a dirci molto,
di cosa stanno facendo gli alberi.
I satelliti - come quelli che riprendono,
che hanno ripreso queste immagini -
riescono di fatto a vedere
i singoli alberi di tutto il pianeta.
Questo satellite, mano a mano,
sta focalizzando proprio
su qui, dove siamo noi.
Ci mostra il parco di Villa Erba,
dove siamo, e i suoi alberi.
Quello è il centro convegni,
quello lì in mezzo.
Io ho un'immagine come questa,
di tutto il pianeta, ogni 5 giorni.
E tramite questo
riesco a vedere, ad esempio,
come sta cambiando
la deforestazione nel mondo.
Questa immagine, questa serie storica,
dal 1984 ci mostra questa zona
della Bolivia, ad esempio,
dove la foresta è stata,
progressivamente, sostituita dai campi.
Queste immagini ci permettono di capire
come cambia il clima
lì dove cambiano le foreste;
ci permettono di capire
come cambiano le nuvole,
quanta biomassa sta cambiando;
ci permettono proprio di cominciare
a quantificare quei valori immateriali
che fino ad oggi non abbiamo
mai messo sul mercato.
E, grazie a queste immagini,
stanno nascendo dei meccanismi,
finalmente, di mercato.
E delle politiche,
come la politica di contrasto
alla deforestazione delle Nazioni Unite,
dove i paesi sviluppati che hanno preso
un grande vantaggio dal petrolio -
viene in mente, ad esempio,
la Norvegia per l'Europa -
stanno trasferendo
risorse economiche, denaro,
ai paesi in via di sviluppo
che accettano di ridurre
il loro livello di deforestazione.
I satelliti, in questo,
giocano un ruolo fondamentale
perché sono gli strumenti
che permettono all'intera
politica ambientale
di prendere funzione
in maniera trasparente
e accettabile da tutte le parti.
I satelliti ci stanno dando
questa visione della Terra:
una visione dall'alto,
quasi come la visione
che da bambini cercavamo
quando salivamo sugli alberi.
In effetti, guardare le cose
un po' così, da lontano,
le rimette nella giusta prospettiva.
Quando guardo la Terra da così –
questa è la foto presa da un satellite
che sta a un milione e mezzo
di chilometri da noi
e che guarda tutta la Terra
continuamente, ogni mezz'ora –
quando guardiamo la Terra da così lontano,
realmente vediamo
che non è una prateria sconfinata.
È realmente una capsula spaziale.
Nella quale viviamo tutti insieme,
con un'atmosfera che è
molto sottile, delicata,
con degli oceani e della terra.
Questa immagine ci fa vedere
che non esistono confini;
è un'unica capsula.
Che dobbiamo, in qualche maniera,
proteggere tutti insieme.
Non ci sono alternative.
E questa immagine ci fa anche capire
il valore che abbiamo
nell'osservare, nel valutare,
nell'apprezzare quello
che abbiamo attorno a noi:
il valore della natura,
il valore degli alberi.
E ritornare a ripensare al valore
delle funzioni che la natura,
e dei servizi che la natura ci offre,
anche se questi non hanno,
attualmente, un prezzo.
Io credo che, solo ripensando a questo -
solo ritornando, nella nostra
vita, ad apprezzarlo -
riusciremo alla fine a costruire un ponte.
Un ponte che collega le due sponde
di questo fiume che è la nostra vita:
la sponda del passato -
dove abbiamo ereditato
gli alberi dai nostri genitori -
e la sponda del futuro,
la sponda dove daremo questi alberi
nelle mani dei nostri figli.
Grazie.
(Applausi)